hey guys it's justine and today i'm
taking you guys on a really fun
adventure
right now i'm at a hotel outside of san
diego but we're going to be heading into
the city and we're going to go and do
some really fun adventures
and my sister is inside the hotel room
right now and she doesn't know it but i
have a little surprise for her
a huge thank you to metro by t-mobile
for sponsoring this video in the last
video that i did with metro by t-mobile
jenna mentioned that she wanted
one of the phones that i had well now
metro has a new plan that they're
running you get two samsung galaxy a20s
unlimited data amazon prime all for 80
when you switch and since the new a20
just recently came out
i got one for jenna so i'm gonna
surprise her with that and since we're
always traveling and doing road trips
and constantly in need of the internet i
got us one of the metro smart hotspots
and we're constantly uploading videos in
the car so we're definitely using this
today and
in the future jenna yo so what are we
gonna do today
uh breakfast and then adventure
okay i'm so excited oh it's so nice
outside today too we should probably go
to torrey pines it's a really
cute state park that they have close by
and then maybe the zoo
i've always wanted to go to the zoo but
no one ever wanted to go with me i'm
sorry i'll take you
i also have a surprise for you but let's
go to breakfast first for me for you
jenna jenna appreciation day that is
usually in february but
it's happening a little late this year
[Music]
so before we head up on our adventures
first and
this place has the best breakfast ever
because this is our buffet like i got
everything i'm so zoomed in right now i
can see the
i can see where this egg came from i can
see the hen
[Music]
we just finished breakfast and we're
about to head out on some adventures but
i have a surprise
for you though for me for surprises
breakfast should i close my eyes
maybe okay okay so in the last video
jenna said that she wanted a phone as
well
here's the thing your ice cream gift a
gift for me a gift for you
goodness this is the new samsung galaxy
a20 this just recently came out metro's
latest deal is two samsung galaxy a20s
unlimited data
amazon prime all for eighty dollars when
you switch really
i know that's an incredible deal yeah
two million box it now yeah go for it
okay there's also another little
surprise this one is for both of us you
love that sticker
it ready so good oh it's so fresh and so
smudge free and i've smudged it i
already have it all activated for you so
we are set for the rest of the day
so this is their smart hot spot you just
turn it on
it makes a wi-fi hotspot and you can
connect to it that's good because guess
what i have a lot of work to do in the
car
so do i that's great our new office our
car i mean honestly we end up
sitting in our car so much working on
the side of the road it's very true
thank you is your phone set up yeah okay
i should probably download the trail map
first because i'm not really sure
where we're gonna be going
[Music]
i think we're finally ready
all right i'm looking at my trail map so
we can figure out where to go because
sometimes they don't tell you where to
start
the trail is there's a bunch of
different trails too because there's
like a beach access there's a north
beach
a phone on a laptop and you want to get
the hotspot out
i'm trying but like i know i do need the
laptop because i have to upload
and you're but i'm also drinking for me
11 yellow minutes everything's sliding
out of the controls
hot spots up i text you the password
we're and we're in right we're in yes
he says we're connected so i think what
we should do is just leave the computer
open and enter the hotspot
while we hike we're on top of this
mountain we are well i also have to
upload a video
so i think it's on that drive so if you
can upload that yeah i'm on it i'm going
to take a look and see what's outside
i'm going to
compare this map
[Music]
there's a high point trail there's the
razer pointer this is two thirds of a
mile this is a half mile loop
what do you want what do you which one
you want okay
i just i just wanted us to have a nice
walk okay
we will
we just saw a small little bird's nest
and a pack rat's nest i've never seen
one before and the pack around actually
the males are not allowed inside of the
pack ratness because
they eat the baby but they stay close by
how do i get a picture of it really
quick i mean that whole thing is it
hello instagram i just want to let you
know that this here
is a pack rat's nest thank you so much
for coming to justine's nature walk
i'll see you next time it's good content
content
[Music]
i've already taken so many photos and
videos since we got here
one of the things that's great is you do
have a google one subscription included
in your metro plan all of my photos and
videos are automatically backed up to
google one
it's a really lovely little hike i need
to look what a pack rat looks like
i don't know what a background no i have
no idea i was trying to play cool
but i don't actually know oh it's small
oh no backrest for dinner oh no they're
little
she made a mansion out there do you
think they'll have them at the zoo
do you think there's gonna be meerkats
at the zoo i mean i don't know
i don't know let's go
[Music]
can you guys believe that we're at the
zoo right now like we made it here
we are here officially jenna's first
time at the zoo
[Music]
we need to reenact something for you
okay it's real it's a real authentic
reaction i was walking
okay jenna said java
that was the reenactment but there
really is java over there should we get
one out do we have now
don't do a job it's called jungle job do
you think it's like ice blended
oh okay which trash we get i want the
giraffe
[Music]
oh my gosh
this is so good now that we've got a
coffee
taking some selfies really making use of
my unlimited data
there's a big jolt coming what do you
mean
did you know about that yeah
[Music]
oh god that's super impressive
oh my goodness
it moved the ear moved oh my gosh it has
arisen
that's what i look like when i would go
from a nap i'm making my lips looking
for candy i can get a custom henna
starting at 25
should we get our face painted or a
hannah tattoo
i think that i want the flamingo
squirrel
if you get the full on cheetah i will
give you a new samsung galaxy 8 20. here
you have it
shoot i will let you have unlimited you
already have unlimited data okay
how much what would you do what would
you do for it for full-length
face paint yes thousand dollars a
thousand dollar
get out of here i'm getting a flamingo
swirl
let me have this i'll get a henna tattoo
okay okay so i'm either gonna do this
skull or the shark
okay i can't see it so you're gonna have
to send it to me okay
nervous scene are you excited thinking
it's going to hurt
no no kind of pride for children
how's it going jess good i just found
out that this lasts for two weeks
jenna told me it lasts for two days i
had a tattoo
fun fact it actually lasts for two weeks
not two days i
only read 20 40 48 hours
i should this is another life lesson to
read the instructions
where do i go now and then i'm just
going to turn you around real quick
let's see it first let's see let's take
a little look
at that whoa yeah how long does it take
to dry about an hour so just be careful
okay oh here we go now she's getting a
what do you get
flamingo swirl you're going to be
beautiful
there you go you're done
no not really no no no
let's see it hello i'm
beautiful look it looks good thank you
this is so cool
it's very cute i thought it got the text
pretty good yeah it looks so great
look at this all right yeah now it's
jenna's turn yay
oh this looks so cool jen i'm not gonna
look until it's done
i couldn't get it on my neck because i
moved too much we've been at the zoo for
about three hours we haven't had coffee
have we what time do we get here
it feels like three hours it feels like
a long time we still haven't seen an
animal yet but we've got tattoos i got
face paint i had a coffee
where are the animals i think that she
said that the elephants are over here
elephant odyssey i think that the
elephants went to the vet she said
are they this is a bear
what am i looking at
[Music]
where are we wait what oh
wow seven to ten that's a big spray do
you think it's
their potty that'd be incredible so
cancel everything i said jenna
the elephants are here look at that butt
oh oh he's turning around dusting up the
place
i'm shooting in regular mode this looks
like he's he's moving so slow this looks
like slow motion
he's eating he's eating oh i forgot i
had face paint on wow
he's coming in for the shot look at his
eyelashes
come on let's go in the photo booth
we've done so many non-animal things
here
smelly in here we'll do meerkats for
jenna oh my gosh the meerkats
look three two
one i was a meerkat uh me too
okay that was not us being meerkats it
wasn't oh there you go oh boy
gosh the zoo is so much fun oh look at
this look at this quality
can we put on your refrigerator we
should get a admit
yes how's my chat looking looks good
it's crumbling which means that it's
setting
that's good i think that's what she's i
once again i didn't read the
instructions we got to read the
instructions
okay no it's real he's looking out he's
eating he's is he eating
you're sleeping no he's looking out
let's go look back
at him oh look at him he wasn't he was
looking at
he was kind of looking a little beard oh
my gosh he is really cute so jenna's
been using her samsung galaxy a20 and
i've been using the samsung galaxy s10
plus i've actually had this phone for
quite a while and i absolutely love it
and one of the cool things about metro
is not only do they have access to top
phones you're actually able to save a
lot of money on your metro plans we just
made our way around the entire zoo and
we made it back to the beginning when we
started which was where the flamingos
were
and now i am one of them
i don't think they understand they're so
cute
look at their little bodies
do you remember when i got facepaint in
the fake tattoo yes big day
is he dying they're all doing it
oh are they possessed this is so strange
maybe they until they eat
or i have a question i have so many
flamingo questions
we just got back to the hotel room i am
exhausted we had a full day of
activities
and jenna's over there watching some
shows
on her phone and one of the things that
we do quite often is we share hotel
rooms and
before she had a phone or would watch
stuff on her computer she would watch
stuff on tv before bed and it would be
so loud it would actually just it would
not be that loud
it was pretty loud with metro you get an
amazon prime account and i honestly
cannot
live without amazon shopping and shows
i don't know like what more could you
want well i want you
to stop talking to me on my show
don't make me come over there i would if
i wasn't not i would not i'm not
because i'm already in my bed well thank
you guys so much for watching we had so
much fun in san diego
and a huge thank you to metro again for
sponsoring this video it was really fun
seeing what other metro options they
have out there especially that hot spot
i look forward to our next adventure but
for now
time to go to sleep okay now here's the
real question
who's gonna get up and turn off the
lights no come on you okay
rock paper scissors one two three shoot
one two three shoot did i cut you
i also cut you oh my gosh i can't see
that far back okay ready
one two three shoot i win
you know what it's you suffocate you
like i'm suffocating in that room
i got we were really cold so i turned
the heat on
it's on it's on like 85. oh my gosh
you're fine okay good night bye guys
thanks for watching